o psol sejam bem vindos e hoje temos um
vídeo patrocinado pela empresa terra que
produz impressoras 3d e hoje vou estar a
implementar um modelo black widow que a
maior emissora quilos tem vou começar
por abrir as caixas depois vou montar e
impressora mais pro final vou imprimir
umas coisas para vocês verem como isso
funciona
perguntar extensora demorei mais ou
menos umas dez horas nos açores
espalhadas pela semana inteira
isto porque tem andado bastante ocupado
agora estou de volta para portugal isto
morar sozinho e por um lado está ocupado
é bastante bom porque quando se mora
sozinho não teremos nada pra fazer então
a gente fica bastante deprimido e em
termos de montagem não foi assim muito
difícil foi até bastante simples em
comparação com o último e vocês
conseguem ver quase todo o espaço é que
neste vídeo aí pois tem algumas
coisinhas mais pequeninas que você não
ver que alguns parafusos que fui
colocando e tal eu mostrasse sintonia
ficar bastante chato mas nos preocupa em
que vocês vão encontrar o manual na
caixa se comprar e por outro lado é uma
coisa muito difícil que é tipo você
estiver em uma dúvida não encontrar lá
podem sempre ir aos grupos do facebook
existem para cada produto
eles fazem um grupo para cada produto
que os criam se tiver algum problema que
podem pôr o vídeo tem esse problema e
depois que a pessoa vai lá e diz olha
faz assim faz a salvar muitas vezes
atenção às pessoas que têm produto que
tentou ajudar outras pessoas que têm
esse produto
então isso é mesmo bacana é bater esses
grupos só para ver o que as outras
pessoas fazem é super engraçado
a copa
tá bom
quando vocês começarem primeiro é muito
importante vocês nivelarem mesa a mesa
esta parte aqui que estou com cara o
vidro por cima pra vocês nivelarem mesa
é bastante simples vocês têm enquanto
profusão nos cantos que podem apertar o
desapertar depois tem que equilibrar o
estudo eram construídas é a quarta que
queria que essa ferramenta para isso
vocês metem de incentivos de filamento
depois carregando a máquina para tirar
10 entre outros
essa máquina tirado novo então é porque
vocês têm que aumentar velocidade e para
finalizar tem que instalar o programa eu
vou usar porque há rostos que o programa
gratuito e eu não consegue porque é
bastante simples de utilizar
é só vocês em primeiro
se vocês quiserem mais informações sobre
esta impressora vai estar um link na
descrição deste vídeo
por que vou utilizar extensora para
imprimir um brinquedo que tenha nada a
fazer há bastante tempo no computador em
3d mas não vou mostrar vos quando eu
acabar hu e ficar tipo em produto final
a isso muito obrigada ter esquecido até
à próxima champions